I added same Clown Posse in studio and I
asked them I said you know magnets are
not actually magic there's science right
and they actually turned it around on me
and they said well how do they work and
I said I don't know they said with an
magic find is a gathering of the
Juggalos and that's what I was gonna do
I was gonna go out there you know when a
negatively charged ion and a positive
share the same space they can't be in
the same man turns out I just wanted to
get out of there with my life I was like
doing my character from the 80s that I
jettison how long into it did you say I
better go back to [ __ ] the character
oh my god I got to the venue I feel
really sure I but I'm not good at family
or something like that yes don't look at
me like this have you been to the
gathering I shot it twice and it was
backwoods of Ohio I don't remember I
don't want to do with Neil deGrasse
Tyson it was it wasn't in Illinois and
we outside of the Columbus I believe
Columbus was the airport I or Lexi
Kentucky but the time I had no there's
no light there's no security no it's
just a fence with about they say a lot
more but it was about 7,000 Peters
there's nothing calming about a clown in
the woods
fires and people just beating each other
up it's like Lord of the Flies like they
suddenly pick somebody like piggy piggy
and they just beat up one of them and
it's it really is the scariest place
I've been and I grew up like in a house
with bikers and so what you're saying is
it's a positive clowns but they're
somehow insane I played the you have to
do a tequila oh my god oh yes you got
rocks and [ __ ] thrown it yeah they
knocked over outhouses and dust
whoo adder yeah it was like an inverted
GG Allin concert yeah there you go
I actually had good success there twice
like I got a shock it was scary to get
there because it was a biology like
where the [ __ ] am I going and then you
show up and there was an outdoor tent
with hay setup but I just did I came and
I did yeah it was greatly shortened and
I did yeah and that was the thing is
like I I think they're really
appreciative yeah that you did it and I
had a I had a okay set but it was the
before and after getting in and out
right did you get paid in cash like I
got it I believe I did yeah plastic
garbage bag you went right back to the
character oh and when I was up on stage
I yeah I'm not that I was like my wife
at the time thought this is gonna be
funny and she's like she tried to dress
like her version of like a boy you like
so here's the thing honey like irony is
not destroyed Juggalo yes did you it was
upchuck the clown you're opening in I
believe he was yeah so when I was there
I think so check that going you got
nothing to worry about it's it's family
it's like a Dave Matthews concert and
I'm like well [ __ ] you it's not like a
Dave Matthews concert and [ __ ] you for
thinking I've ever been to a day and so
to story that says I left my hatchet at
home so he's driving me around in a golf
cart there's a golf cart there and and
like and and and and we're going through
the grounds and the jugglers are getting
out of the way like we're like you know
who are the millionaire's they're sorry
to God
a can of Faygo first of all no first
this guy runs alongside the golf cart
and just punches him right in the face
and an object just hits the gas he goes
I'm here every year they know me
[Laughter]
James Bond knock him out with a kid I
thought I helped him do this trailer
that was a dressing room kind of thing
and I mean if a go out his head for the
song of course you did
one more Jim and Sam catch up with full
episodes and interviews from celebrity
guests anytime on demand using the
Sirius XM app
[Music]